It's actually very gratifying to give this topic presentation because 10 years ago, around
this time, I actually had my first patient on a Bispecific study achieve complete remission.
And that patient, nowadays when you think about it, only got one-tenth of the approved
dose, but the patient continues to stay in remission, it's been 10 years now.
So here are my disclosures.
So we know that when a new therapy go into clinical development, we usually ask two questions.
Does it work?
And can it be given safely?
So for a Bispecific, I think these days, there's really no doubt that the answer to
these two questions are increasingly yes.
So for lymphoma, there are currently already four Bispecific approved in lymphoma
setting, three of them FDA approved, and one of them is only approved in Europe.
But there's a lot of work to be done.
Thank you.
So the question is, how do we deliver this Bispecific to the patient that we think will
benefit the most?
So in follicular lymphoma, we really see the patient as a Bispecific, and we see the patient's
Bispecific, and we see the patient's Bispecific, and we see the patient's Bispecific, and we see the patient's Bispecific.
So the question is, how do we deliver this Bispecific to the patient that we think will benefit the most?
So in follicular lymphoma, we really see the patient as a Bispecific, and we see the patient as a Bispecific.
two. So all three by specific antibody pivotal trials have very similar high efficacy. We look
at the complete response rate is at least 60%. And for the first time, we have five-year follow-up
data, most on the trisomab. So at the end of around five years, what I have the patient still
stays in remission. And the overall survival is 78% at five years, which is pretty comparable
to those in the third-line patient treated with CAR-T. When we look at the toxicities and
stratified profile, bispecifics are also pretty favorable, which very few patients had
neurologic toxicities consistent with ICANs. And cytokine release syndromes are mostly low-grade.
So folicolinforma bispecific is not just as a salvage option. It's actually no longer a
salvage option. So one of the most exciting trials that
has been done in the last five years is the one that has been done in the last five years.
We have seen these days for folicolinforma using bispecifics, really the availability
of bispecific apcoridomide in the second-line setting. This is really based on the recently
published and presented phase three study. This one comparing apcoridomide plus R-squared
versus R-squared in the randomized fashion. And both primary endpoints were met. Efficacy-wise,
complete remission rate over survival rate, overall response rate much higher than those from R-squared.
And for progression-free survival, also much favor the treatment group using apcoridomide plus R-squared
with an absolute reduction of 79%, and also with a very high and low hazard ratio of 0.21.
So the significance of this study is it really established the bispecific role in early-line
treatment in folicolinforma. And it also really leads the way when we talk about sequencing bispecific and CAR-T.
Now, bispecific apcoridomide is the only bispecific or T-cell-engaging immunotherapy
available in a second-line setting. CAR-T is only available in a third-line setting. So in most
patients, folicolinforma nowadays, I think it's pretty easy to say sequencing-wise, bispecific
first, and CAR-T as a salvage in most patients. And there are also two other ongoing phase three
clinical trials looking at also other Bispecific, most on land or adrenoxamide land,
you know, in this, you know, space. And whether we really need the actual rituximab is not known.
So moving on into large basal lymphoma, you know, we know that there are many,
many novel agents approved, you know, for large basal lymphoma in the last, you know,
10 years. And CAR-T is already approved in a second-line setting. In the third-line setting,
you know, bispecific already established based on two pivotal trials that led to the approval of apcoridomide
and glufetamide, you know, in the third-line space, you know, back in 2023. And both, you know,
provides good salvage options for those patients with aggressive lymphoma and most likely, you know,
post-CAR-T setting. However, there's also, you know, we know that really good momentum testing
by specific antibodies in earlier-line treatment. You know, 10 years ago, you know, I was struggling
to field in the spa, but now we're really talking about phase two or phase three clinical trials in,
you know, aggressive basal lymphoma setting, just, you know, it's really difficult to highlight each
of them. I don't have enough time here. So, for four of the phase three clinical trials
looking at by specific role in the second-line setting, you know, two of them already completed,
you know, StarGlo, which looking at glufetamide plus Argemox, you know, this was a positive study,
however, it didn't really receive FDA approval. And SAMO study was, you know, just published and
presented and this, you know, this regimen, most on the tooth mass or polar tooth mass was actually
just approved in Japan as the first global approval. So, hopefully, the role for FDA approval
won't be that long and whiny. So, both, you know, both glufetamide plus the Argemox and most on the
tooth mass plus polar tooth mass now already listed in the NCCN guidelines as either category one or
category two.
Okay. So, we have a question here. So, I think the increasing number of patients really receiving
these by specific antibody in the second-line setting, you know, in those who are not transplant
intended and not CAR-T intended, but I think they're also available for those patients now
who might want to consider using by specific regimen in the second-line setting,
either as a bridge to CAR-T or as a more definitive treatment.
A longer-term follow-up will need, will be needed to really assess their curability. So, there are
more ongoing phase three studies now even in the front-line setting. None of this is mature yet,
but this is really no doubt, you know, by specific really moving to earlier lines, you know,
treatment in large B-cell lymphoma. I'm also very excited about the Bispecific role in mental cell
lymphoma. There's a really strong signal. If you look at glufetamide, most on polar, these are
single-arm phase two studies are completed in comparison to Braxosal, Lysosal, Cartesinal. It's
in the third-line setting. Now, if you look at the patient population, other than glufetamide,
phase two study, which, you know, may be a population of patient with, you know,
less prior-line therapy, you know, only have a patient Btk exposed, but all the other patients
enrolled on the most on polar, Braxosal, Lysosal, heavily pre-treated, all Btk inhibitor exposed.
But look at the CR rate. So, this is really a subtype of lymphoma that the Bispecific response
rate is, you know, very low. But if you look at the CR rate, you know, in the third-line setting,
at least the CNS, you know, Cartes, and, you know, we don't have long enough follow-up to
assess the durability yet, but it's very promising. And when you look at the toxicity profile,
this is really the differentiating factor, especially looking at most on polar,
in the lay-line refractory setting, you know, it's outpatient regimen, you know,
fixed duration, and extremely well tolerated. So, currently, both glufetamide, most on polar,
already listed as NCCA and GABA. So, you know, it's very low. So, you know, if you look at the
guidelines as the newest version in the 2026 publication, and so they are increasingly
available for those patients with real-life refractory mental cell lymphoma, a phase three
study is ongoing currently to see whether there's a role for glufetamab, you know, in the second-line
setting. So, how I precision by specific antibodies in 2026, you know, it's not just a CAR-T alternative.
It's a major off-the-shelf immunotherapy. It's the most established in this using follicle lymphoma,
and it's a standard here in lay-line, the large piece of lymphoma, but it's really moving forward
to earlier lines. And when we look at using Bispecific, the success really relies on
how we design the infrastructure support, how we manage patients in the outpatient setting,
how to select the best patient, and last but not the least, is how do we expand the access
of bispecific in the community setting. I think that's a really major focus in 2026.
And here, just a highlight of bispecific lymphoma.
So, tomorrow, there'll be more discussion on bispecific use in lymphoma. Thank you.